c'est quoi aujourd'hui votre votre vie
quotidienne ainsi qu'aux mutations 600
euros de plus alors manger à merci merci
non sur vous merci mon recevoir au nom
des taxis de france et je venu ici avec
je pense qu'en fait c'est plus que pour
les taxis de france c'est pour les
routiers les ambulanciers avec les
auto-écoles les infirmières on a parlé
monsieur turaci thaler le discours que
vous tournez je vous respecte mais se
disent pour les fringues
ce discours les français et y en a plein
dans lequel lequel elle le kent et c'est
mieux ailleurs
soucie pas de la politique n'a rien dit
on n'a pas anticipé on est tributaire
deux noms on attendait d'un gouvernement
que ce soit celui-là qui n'est pas
premier ministre argue analyse je
le travaille tous les jours ils font qui
font les courses qui font leur carburant
il atteint le cas - donner leurs
gouvernements mais on et laisse les
taxes il est là le soleil oakley
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui aujourd'hui me
collard mois pour moi ces six ans depuis
samedi c'est 600 euros de plus par mois
de carburant j'ai des collègues taxi
c'est 400 euros parce qu'il travaille un
tout petit peu moins ça va jusqu'à 1000
euros pour des chauffeurs de taxi qui
viennent d'acheter travaillons beaucoup
font des seize heures par jour je vous
conte pas les ambulances je vous conte
pas les routiers qui ne peuvent plus ils
peuvent plus reporter les marges ils
n'en peuvent plus les cas et firmi
regrets quand on est taxé à son compte
aujourd'hui on peut mettre la clé sous
la porte pas encore mais quand on entend
ça deviens septembre il sera peut-être à
3 ou 3 50 même là aujourd'hui c'est une
quête ans pour certains d aucun moment
donné moi je je je je suis patient une
caméra mais qu'est ce que vous attendez
du gouvernement attend son étang lavinay
de conjoncturelle qui joue sol et ça on
attends moi le chèque de 100 euros qui a
eu il ya pas longtemps ça c'est
électrique mais comme cela que je
m'attendais à cette question le problème
c'est qu'une voiture on lâche un jeu pas
comme une casserole à la raison a lancé
touati touché locale par ailleurs par
rapport aux chocs pétroliers toutes
choses égales par ailleurs 9 73 79 pour
situer sa sexuelle c'est complètement
différent je sais non mais à l'époque
nommé justement j'ai pas la question on
était beaucoup plus dépendants je parle
pas évidemment que de la voiture un bon
sens large notre dépendance de notre
économie si vous voulez par rapport au
pétrole a été divisé par deux et demi
par rapport à 73 donc c'est différent
par contre là ce qui est plus douloureux
c'est que son cousin toutes les matières
premières a pas que le pétrole et le
drame s'est effectivement aujourd'hui
des pénuries ça veut dire vous avez
pendre dans le secteur automobile là
vous avez des deux constructeurs est
choquée effectivement on les voitures
prêtes mais il manque des immondes et
propose un et on a effectivement tous
les cours de l'aluminium du nickel qui a
pignon exploser complètement le marché
de l'occasion a explosé d'ailleurs
exactement donc c'est ça qui
effectivement est particulièrement
dangereux là on a une difficulté
supplémentaire c'est que encore une fois
on a un euro qui baissent donc c'est ça
qui tous qui avez marre qu'il faut
continuer d'acheter le gaz russe ou pas
selon que vous voilà évidemment le alors
encore une fois le problème ça parce que
l'embargo que les américains n'ont aucun
américain appelait donc bon on ne suit
pas sinon vivre après il faut s'adresser
l'économie allemande est déconseillé aux
après on fait ce qu'on veut évidemment
mais sauf que si aujourd'hui comme je
tends le calme ans parce que nous on dit
ça ouais on le cas mais pour nos amis
allemands si demain ils arrêtent le gaz
russe l'économie allemande s'est offert
hier ils sont déjà en récession et
surtout n'oubliez pas ça c'est très
important on sort de deux ans de
pandémie et pendant deux ans on était
bloqué donc on a eu l on a en france à 8
500 milliards d'euros d'augmentation de
la dette publique et donc ses 5 grammes
chez dia bruno le maire pendant laquelle
j ai faites attention vous dépenser trop
il faut garder des cartouches alors la
prochaine crise heureusement la crise
générale ça arrive tous les dix ans là
c'est arrivé deux mois après le violent
là on dirait monsieur c'est là qu'il fit
halte là on n'est pas d'accord on sort
de deux ânes de pandémie on a bien vu
les ados qui ont été distribués l'argent
est là le gouvernement doit baisser les
taxes on le sait qu'on est d'accord ce
moment là
nicolas nommé marc la demande de nicolas
laisser les tacles et alors ce cycle est
donc c'est possible ou paniers de marge
de manoeuvre du gouvernement alors il ya
une solution très simple ce combat qu'on
l'ait toujours pas appliqué ce avait été
appliqué des années 2000 c'est ce qu'on
appelle la taxe parce qu'effectivement
sur ollon be le plein d'essence et à 60%
grecque 60% des rites ses ténors folie
non évidemment c'est clair qu'ils vont
dans les caisses de l'état oui mais
encore ils sont les départements les
régions par exemple prévoir que ça fait
bizarre 30 % des budgets des régions
deviennent des taxes d'accord
distribuerait parce que tout le monde va
les orignaux des positions
suivantes en supprime effectivement
c'est je suis pas de gauche ou pour
baisser les impôts de façon les numéros
1 des impôts dans le monde en france
donc il faut bien sûr baisser les impôts
ça c'est sûr il faut savoir qu'après
faut trouver un moyen de compenser tout
ça si on veut garder le même niveau de
dépenses au niveau de prestations
sociales et tout ce qu'on peut imaginer
exactement alors par contient une dose
ça n'était quoi oui mesure qui est
tripier très simple si vous voulez qu'on
appelle la taxe flottante oui ça veut
dire que justement quand le prix du p en
gros on va garantir un certain niveau de
roeux de recettes fiscales pour l'état
sur le pétrole est prévue des produits
pétroliers et donc le prix du pétrole
augmente comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
ce moment on va réduire cette taxe pour
garantir le même niveau de revenu
effectivement à l'état mais pour que les
prix à la pompe ne montrent pas un mois
la veine de solution concrète n'est
arrivée non mais ça ne plaît pas c'est
le mec ce que ça vous êtes impliqué e
vous savez si on la met en place puisque
vous êtes économiste les raisons oui
mais cela dépend ce que laissait pas
seulement ça c'est qu'après quand le bel
le prix du baril redescend plus personne
n'osera augmenter les taxes parce que
politiquement ça ne passe plus vous
savez donc que c'est pour ça que mes
petits pp non je vous souhaite le
ministère des ressources ont été mis en
place donc je vous remercie de j'ai
compris ce que je veux vous dire par là
c'est que c'est pas si évident que ça
parce que déjà c'est une recette
fiscales qui s'effondrent donc tout le
monde veut de tous en france on réclame
de pouvoir faire tout pour thierry cham
a écouté ce qu'il maniait surtout le
prix augmente donc les taxes sont plus
importants il te dit de les laisser au
moins au niveau actuel
très bien compris et monsieur zier aussi
non monsieur j'ai très bien compris ça
existe on l'a déjà fait et d'ailleurs
c'est la droite qui l'a fait mais on
aura ce que je vous dis souvent mais on
n'a pas réussi parce que vous vous avez
bien mais vous savez bien qu'après on ne
peut pas réorienter si vous voulez parce
que c'est flottant justement c'est une
formule